[Musique]
la nouvelle édition du 7 8 m de haut sur
tv 78 merci de nous rejoindre voici les
titres de ce 7 décembre
des images l'adolescent interpellé à
mantes la jolie en réponse à des
violences perpétrées lors de
manifestations lycéennes font polémique
inspecteur de l'académie préfet se sont
exprimés face à la presse ce matin avant
un échange avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et le maire d'elancourt
annonce d'ores et déjà être candidat à
un cinquième mandat l'élection devrait
se dérouler en 2020 jean michel fourgous
également président de saint quentin en
yvelines est l'invité de cette édition
et puis comme chaque semaine l'essentiel
de l'actualité du salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise auquel l'agglomération
participer aux festivités organisées
pour anouk à des adolescents menottes
dans le dos à genoux devant les forces
de l'ordre ce sont les images prises à
mantes la jolie et qui sont relayées sur
les réseaux sociaux et les chaînes
d'information est depuis ce vendredi
matin mais que vous ne verrez pas
aujourd'hui sur notre antenne afin de ne
pas alimenter la colère et dans
l'attentes d'éléments d'information
concret à communiquer car c'est bien là
le travail des journalistes nous avons
fait le choix de ne pas les mettre en
avant de façon brute pour ne pas céder
au sensationnalisme et néanmoins nous ne
pouvons passer à côté de cette polémique
qui enfle les réactions des politiques
se sont multipliées par fois contrastée
pour valérie pécresse présidente de la
région l'obsession des policiers c'est
de ne pas blesser un lycéen et elle
voudrait qu'on se félicite qu à mantes
la jolie
il n'y a pas eu de blessés mais pour
benoît hamon ancien député des yvelines
leader du mouvement générations la
situation est inadmissible
il parle d'une jeunesse française
humilié une conférence de presse commune
du préfet de l'inspecteur d'académie des
proviseurs également des lycées de
mantes-la-jolie a eu lieu ce vendredi
matin écouter est leur déclaration
lorsqu'on a plus de 150 personnes à
gérer comme on dit pour qu'elle puisse
être dépouillés de leurs armes qu'on
analyse qui se passe
les policiers sur place ont décidé de
faire comme ça je ne dis pas que c'est
la méthode la plus optimale jeudi
qu'elle n'est pas contraire aux lois et
règlements il n'y a pas eu un blessé par
une écorchure pas une plainte
le mode opératoire qui a été celle qui a
été choisi par don
ne m'appartient pas ce que je comprends
évidemment c'est le choc que ça provoque
chez nos enseignants j'en appelle
évidemment à la responsabilité des uns
et des autres nous communiquons en ce
sens avec les parents nous prenons
toutes les précautions nécessaires aucun
établissement de ce département n'est
fermé que l'accueil est assuré jean
michel fourgous
bonjour et bienvenue sur ce plateau
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
maire d'elancourt
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction tout de
même en tant que responsable politique
face à ces images qui ont été diffusées
depuis ce matin de d'étudiants de deux
jeunes adolescents menotté et me john
waters écoutez on est devant une
situation je pense où notre pays a
peut-être trop souvent écouté des
minorités agissantes
est ce que l'on voit très rigides et
jaunes pour en revenir
première étape c'est je pense c'est une
sorte de majorité silencieuse qui vient
souvent aussi de province un bon et qui
a envie aussi d'être écoutés parce que
sony mal assise nationale quand il y
avait tous et tous ces mouvements
sociaux etc ont voté une loi contre la
fessée c'est vrai que ça fait rigoler
tout le monde donc il faut bien voir que
l'autorité ça existe s'il est bien un
point que l'on ne discute pas dans
l'émission égalé dans l'île sur des
tasses et l'autorité je crois que là il
ya eu des déficits je pense de
d'autorité de l'état
je crois que le préfet
mot donc tout nouveau préfet à agir et
avec discernement avec fermeté mais je
pense que là lorsque des jeunes de 14 à
16 ans envoyé prennent des sortes de
d'armes presque pour blesser ou pour
pour taper ou une et qu'il y en a qui
ont dépouillé des je crois un des
conducteurs d'automobiles enfin on l'a
on bien sûr que je pense que c'est bien
de faire un rappel à la loi
s'était fait sans incident aucun blessé
aucun mort je rappelle que on en est
quand même à près de quatre morts depuis
les jo d'été gilet jaune donc là ça
devient une voie là ça devient quand
même un peu professionnel et c'est bien
que je pense qu'il ait eu cette réaction
pression même si effectivement oui
écouter quand quand on veut les inscrits
avec la police oui on peut être exposé à
être momentanément bien sûr arrêter
rendre des comptes à la nation on dira
que démolir du matériel
qui est financé par les contribuables en
finale c'est toujours contre fc leurs
parents gérard tiné qui payent tous
avons donc là c'est rien
d'extraordinaire alors j'ai vu que
monsieur hamon comme d'habitude joue les
incendiaires va va parler d'humiliation
pour parler d'une fête cette année on le
voit pour en fait excité ces jeunes oui
si vous parler d'humiliation enfin c'est
le bon voilà ils ont ils ont voulu un
peu poussé la règle voir où la règle
allez allez ça s'arrêtait qu'elle était
là mais voilà ils ont eu de façon très
simple très professionnel voilà c'est
voilà le commentaire que j'ai à faire
maintenant le gnc j'en vois tous les
jours des gens y tuer moi j'envoie tout
à l'heure avant donc aujourd'hui ce
après midi gilet jaune qui est des
encours je t'ai vu sur un plateau donc
j'écoute et je l'invité à vous
rencontrer pour recueillir cesser ses
suggestions et puisque vous parlez des
gilet jaune justement est ce sera juste
avant un dernier mot sur sur cette
situation en prévision de ce samedi de
mobilisation gérard larcher le président
du sénat ce sénateur des yvelines estime
que la république est en danger vous
partager ce point de vue c'est vrai que
quand on a cette violence
ce que vous y allez gilet jaune à côté
qui ont une certaine légitimité il faut
le reconnaître
moi j'en peux plus d'avoir des
règlements qui sont faits par des gens
mais qui n'ont pas la compétence
c'est pas acceptable de laisser le
processus décisionnel français d'abord
monopolisé par une école de
fonctionnaires complètement complètement
en rupture avec le monde de l'entreprise
avec la mondialisation
enfin les normes pas en parler c'est ccc
en fait l'écho de la plus archaïque du
monde c'est une école de fonctionnaires
il pour former l'élite qui va diriger la
france prône une illusion c'est bizarre
et puis c'est on vous apprend de tout
état on vous apprend que toutes les
questions seul l'étape peut répondre à
faire une action enfin et puis en plus
bon voilà on voit comment ils gèrent
joueur vous avez envie une beauté
indicible budget de 4 milliards enfin
jacques les leçons qu'on donne au maire
quand on leur dit on va en plus vous
enlevez la taxe d'habitation
c'est en tout cas ce que c'était bien
mouvementée chez les jaunes d'oeufs des
casseurs et mais cette élite 2 mois se
prononçait pas c'est pas les sommes que
c'est ce système cette culture que je
pense qu'il faut que la france quitte
cette culture la dirigeante
technocratique ardente et reviennent à
la réalité a des gens compétents terrain
voilà c'est tout dans le reste de
l'actualité est également le suppléant
de la députée florent second but qui a
claqué la porte de la république en
marche et aymeric laval explique i par
accompagné de l'assistante parlementaire
de là
depardon qui part donc de voiliers la
députée pardon de la 12e circonscription
son assistant et son assistante et son
suppléant ont décidé de remettre ça dans
l'ordre de l a quittée de lâcher la
république en marche ils avaient tous
les deux rejoint le mouvement en 2016 il
s'estime maintenant elle trahit il
déclare alors qu'emmanuel mâcon avait
promis d'insuffler un souffle nouveau
rien n'a changé la république en marche
est devenu un parti comme les autres
la députée qui entend réserver pour
l'instant sa réponse à nos confrères du
parisien qui ont publié à l'information
ce matin elle jean michel fourgous vous
restez en plateau on va parler à de
votre actualité cette candidature un
cinquième mandat de maire à elancourt ce
sera juste après ce reportage dorer les
ronces qui revient et sur les smart days
de la cci ce vendredi la cinquième
édition s'est déroulée à guyancourt sur
le site de bouygues construction rendez
vous qui a pour objectif de donner une
nouvelle dimension à la stratégie
d'entreprise thème choisi cette année
d'intelligence artificielle
une journée placée sous le signe du
business et de l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est le principe de la 5e édition des
smart days organisés par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
au sein du siège de bouygues
construction à guyancourt mais je pense
que ça thème intéressant important parce
qu'il devient mature pour les
entreprises
l'intelligence artificielle est un peu
partout dans la vie dans les domaines
d'activité et c'est important aussi
d'apporter des éléments aux entreprises
du territoire sur l'intelligence
artificielle grands comptes pme et
start-up étaient présents pour faire
découvrir leurs technologies innovantes
mais aussi renforcer leurs réseaux
depuis six ans cette entreprise
yvelinois s'est spécialisé dans
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
relation client fait on va être capable
de créer des robots conversationnel donc
cessons des robots qui vont être
capables de comprendre des requêtes
d'humains et d'y répondre
automatiquement
donc si vous avez un problème par
exemple à 4 heures du matin mais en fait
vous allez pouvoir interagir avec un
robot conversationnel parce que lui il
est capable de vous répondre tout de
suite de son côté cette entreprise
toulousaine soutenu financièrement par
bouygues construction a développé des
solutions d'assistance vocale au
technicien présente dans cet espace
d'exposition elle est à la recherche de
nouveaux clients des contacts
avec des grosses des gros industriels ou
des entreprises de taille intermédiaire
qui pourrait avoir des besoins de ce
type de technologie dont condé
technicien qui des techniciens qui
travaillent à partir de papiers ou à
partir de documents qui sont un peu
complexe et où notre assistant pour
aider aider à mieux travailler
une cinquième édition qui a vu sa
fréquentation augmenter par rapport à
l'année dernière avec près de 600
personnes inscrites première élection en
tant que maire 1996 jean michel fourgous
entend décrocher un cinquième mandat en
2020 l'échéance peut apparaître
lointaine et pourtant il a d'ores et
déjà annoncé sa candidature pour quoi
vous déclarez aussitôt moi je n'ai
déclaré du tout ça poser la question
vous avez répondu non mais parce que
monsieur mêlant d'un donc maire de
trappes a commencé à tourner entre
guillemets il a lancé sa candidature et
à lens alors après on est venu me
demander ce que vous allez bon du côté
tout le monde sait très bien que c'est
il encourait elancourt aujourd'hui est
au coeur d'une vraie innovation on vient
encore je crois d'avoir il ya quelques
jours à prix de l'innovation lors en
plus ont été les trois premiers mais on
a appris qu'on était médaille d'or dans
cette marche d'innovation donc voilà on
c'est passionnant d'innover surtout
quand ça marche à tous qu'on innove sur
des sujets est en cours et est devenu en
fait un exemple pas seulement français
mais européen
donc on est visitée vaillant par le
canada qu'il ne nous visiter récemment à
corée la chine la russie la suède
donc voilà entrailles nous sur le sûr en
fait le parcours à l encours sur le
parcours éducatif la vienne il ya
surtout de l'arrêt vos mandats jusqu'à
présent oui et en étant un expert de
l'éducation j'ai écrit plusieurs livres
là dessus je suis un doctorat de
psychologie là dessus j'ai bien sûr que
c'est extraordinaire ça l'est encore est
devenue le laboratoire pour demain mais
peut-être à augmenter les résultats
scolaires des enfants de 30%
c'est un objectif que l'ours et c'est
sur le long terme n'est sûr mais on
monte en pression
je vois que maintenant l'éducation
nationale ou suis pour que le modèle
elancourt monte au niveau de tout saint
quentin et ensuite que vous ayez une
espèce de parcours de la réussite donc
primaire l'école primaire ensuite le
collège le département nous suit pour
pour transformer aussi cette nouvelle
pédagogie
ces nouvelles façons d'apprendre dans le
lycée madame pécresse aussi il me suit
et dans l'université paris saclay
première université française qui va
être comme ça nous on a pas tous le 1er
janvier 2020
idem il ya une continuité de ce nouveau
modèle très innovant pour apprendre et
cette université vous avez avoir un
campus le plus gros campus français
universitaire de 70 mille étudiants près
et qui va aussi sur profiter de toute
cette nouvelle façon d'apprendre dont
vous voyez c'est un projet exceptionnel
la fin quand un jeune une famille dans
courtois demain pour envoyer son enfant
dans la première université française
qui seront même rempli l'université
américaine puisque vous rentrer dans le
top 20 de shanghai et sens en payer le
prix qu'il faut mettre pour henri son
enfant d'universités américaines ont
donc voilà un peu ça c'est un projet
magnifique qu'est sur le long terme
tous les acteurs sont avec nous donc que
vous voulez encore accompagner et c'est
aussi peut-être ce qui motive votre vie
votre candidature juste pour pour
avancer un petit peu il ya de nombreux
maires qui ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'il ne se représenterait pas parce que
c'était difficile qu'ils n'avaient plus
de reconnaissance des steam même et puis
des budgets de plus en plus difficile à
boucler
on vous en parlait souvent mais ces
baisses de dotations sont très
difficiles pour les communes ça ne vous
décourage pas bah faudrait que je les
comprends amer sur deux ya de quoi parce
que quand on vous fait diminuer tous vos
moyens de 20 à 30% enfin c'est comment
voulez-vous même s'ils jouent baisse de
1 30% vos moyens pour télévision
d'imaginer à faire vous allez voir c'est
c'est terrible donc je comprends cette
situation d'autant plus en plus avec la
présidente annonce pour serrer lire
uniquement avant les élections et lyon
je vais vous supprimer un impôt la taxe
d'habitation enfin c'est d'abord
n'importe quoi c'est pas sérieux
on enlève la limite je peux passer mais
il ya des communes ils vivent à 80 % la
taxe d'habitation comment peut-on faire
faut vraiment ne pas connaître ce monde
des élus locaux des qui font un travail
formidable donc nommé le c'est un mandat
passionnant d'être mère plus que député
d'ailleurs c'est un mandat réel où vous
pouvez vraiment changer les choses et
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle une
soissons l'éducation grâce au numérique
devient l'outil le plus puissant pour
changer le monde
donc quand vous travaillez sur un sujet
comme ça que ça a été aussi votre vie
universitaire avant et vos études de
chercheurs
oui non mais c'est passionnant surtout
quand on monte maintenant labo puisqu'on
nous a également confié vous le savez la
présidence de l'agglo est encore donc
très bien ce qui fait que on est au
coeur de tous les gros partenaires qui
vont nous aider dans ces moments
difficiles pour elle en cours aussi bas
c'est vrai vaut mieux être avec des
partenaires puissants comme l'europe qui
s'intéresse beaucoup à tous les projets
innovants que nous avons que soit l'île
de france ile de france première région
d'europe avec mme pécresse
le département des yvelines un des plus
riches de france paris saclay on est
dans un jeu rappelle on est enfin saint
quentin en yvelines elancourt 50 ans
nuit paris saclay paris saclay c'est là
l'espace le plus innovant du monde
d'après le dans les huit zones les plus
innovantes du monde après le meti donc
cessé en norme
on a effectivement danser dans ce club
des cinq europe région département par
cette lettre saint quentin bien sûr ils
encourent c'est une forme de protection
assez extraordinaire en plus on s'entend
bien et en présidant bien sûr de l'agglo
ça ne nuit pas vous en doutez aux grands
projets de saint-quentin être de violon
cordes et l'encouragent d'elancourt bien
sûr parce que vous avez effectivement
les deux casquettes de président de 50
pages est lâché et maire d'elancourt
j'ai lâché le département oui parce que
c'est pas parce que j'ai été obligé
j'aurais pu le garder mais honnêtement
il faut joindre 12 14 heures voire 16
heures par jour
c'est passionnant la mairie à
l'agglomération voyez pas le temps
passer en fait un job à turin c'est vrai
mais en même temps c'est quand même
voilà il faut donc les deux elancourt et
50 ans est complètement compatible
puisque aujourd'hui une interco il faut
il faut il faut comprendre ça pour les
mères qui démissionnent bien sûr les
intercoms elles font la moitié du
travail maintenant c'est mon fils à moi
cadrée alors les mais c'est encore les
maires ont enfoncé pouvoir ressentir
mais c'est assez désagréable pour un
maire alors heureusement moi je suis le
maire mais l'autre moitié c'est alors ça
mais pour les autres oui je comprends
que ce soit frustrant qu'est qu'on ait
donné autant de pouvoirs aux interco est
alors j'essaye moi d'être très sympa ce
que pop avec tous mes collègues maires
bien sûr et ça se passe bien et vous
remarquerez que il ya un certain une
certaine sérénité qui règne en tout cas
à saint quentin en yvelines et c'est
mieux pour bien travailler on pas parler
tout de suite de programmes il est
encore peut-être un peu tôt mais
peut-être d'equipe aussi vous qu'il
serait candidat il y aura à d'ores et
déjà des nouveaux noms vous allez
préparer aussi peut-être la succession
il ya de nombreuses communes ou les
mères on dit quelquefois fond le mandat
de trop ne pense pas à l'avenir est ce
que vous pensez à l'avenir de votre
commune écoutez je travaille tout
d'abord sur des sujets d venir ce soit
chez palau soit le pôle bien sûr
éducatif qui est quand même reconnu
vivre alors par avenir je parlais pas
des projets je parlais plus d'une autre
personne pour diriger la commune une
fois que vous passerez mais il faut il
faut des talents si vous travaillez sur
un projet éducatif de ce niveau là zemma
intérêt à voir des gens nés d'éprouver
goût idem en sécurité demain on va être
on nous a alloué là le comice à
d'agglomération de saint-quentin genk
est une des grosses agglomérations en
france
bien sûr il va falloir être très à la
hauteur le faire avec des spécialistes
bien sûr donc vous avez également des
projets sportifs je rappelle que on a on
devient sites olympiques
il encourt que cette colline d'elancourt
il va falloir qu'elle soit une des mieux
décoré de france voir donc on a décidé
de l'école bleu blanc rouge
vous êtes regardé par 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs dans le monde c'est
l'événement le plus médiatisé on l'a
vécu avec la ryder cup qui était assez
extraordinaire je répète la ryder cup on
a on a enregistré plus d'un milliard de
vues donc le nom de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient cités plus d'un
milliard de fois dans la presse donc
augmentation de la notoriété de
l'attractivité pour faire des
entreprises sur l'ensemble de sa
chronique dont ils encourent et et bien
sûr augmentation de la fierté
d'appartenance d'ailleurs à saint
quentin pour chaque commune bien sûr
donc tout ça mais ça va plutôt cesser
ses traits c'est un très gros projet
d'organiser et quatre sites olympiques à
cinquantaine dont il encourt un site bon
tout ça bien sûr le fleurissement
on va avoir des pistes cyclables aussi
beaucoup plus encore améliorée parce que
vous nous allons devenir la capitale
mondiale du vélo sur les quatre sites
vous avez trois jeux revel vous rappelle
que l'encours 1 km d'îles en course et
le vélo donne aux jeunes le goût l'a
bien compris en vélodrome du monde dont
bat saint-quentin encore saint quentin
voilà et même au delà de ça donc bien
sûr il ya des très gros projet sportif
on en est un nouveau gymnase direct
enfin de se construire on a des pistes
cyclables qui sont en train de bien sûr
de se démultiplier
on a alors au niveau sportif on a
beaucoup d'activités ces jeux olympiques
que l'on prépare alors après il ya les
transports sur lequel bien sûr et je
vais vous interromps parce qu'on va plus
avoir assez de temps pour couvrir
l'ensemble de cette émission mais on
aura l'occasion d'en voir d'en reparler
et de l'intégralité de ses projets
la campagne sera longue il reste encore
quelques encore deux ans rentre même si
les élections ne sont pas reprises pour
2020 ou quinze mois voilà pour être très
précis restaient encore en plateau à peu
avec nous ont pas se résumer de la
semaine
[Musique]
le monde de l'immobilier d'entreprise
était au palais des congrès à paris
cette semaine pendant trois jours les
différents acteurs étaient rassemblés
pour une 17e édition de l'événement
parmi eux saint quentin en yvelines
paris saclay ou encore le département
des yvelines nicolas landry ce bâtiment
de 18 mille mètres carrés s'appelle
native un projet de démolition
reconstruction place choiseul à montigny
le bretonneux opérationnel en 2021 avec
un bail déjà signé avec l'entreprise
orange l'opération est menée par le
groupe codic promoteurs immobiliers
présents sur le territoire depuis 2000
vraiment saint quentin est un très bel
cour de récréation pour nous c'est une
ville qui a été construite très
rapidement dans les années 60 70
donc il ya pas mal de bâti à reconvertir
ex que nous pouvons offrir à saint
quentin c'est de venir avec des
architectes de renom saint quentin en
yvelines c'est près de 5 millions de m²
d'immobilier d'entreprise 2018 une année
record avec 222 1500 mètres carrés de
transactions et un taux de vacance de 5
5% et une complémentarité avec les
autres territoires de paris saclay on a
ce travail avec eux de mise en connexion
de tout le pôle économique de saint
quentin en yvelines avec les forces
académique de recherche sur l'ensemble
de paris sacré paris-saclay ses trois
pôles un pôle culturel à versailles un
pôle économique
donc à saint quentin et un pôle
scientifique à saclay donc les trois
poules travaillent ensemble à preuve bon
et on est également dans le même conseil
d'administration qui s'appelle le pea
paris saclay en jouant régulièrement le
simi l'occasion aussi de nouer de
nouvelles relations c'est le cas avec
cicas hospitality exploitant hôtelier
présent en angleterre et aux pays bas
il ya énormément d'entreprises c'est
quelque chose d'assez un territoire
dynamique qui est reste une zone
d'attrait pour beaucoup de clients
corporate et donc de fait peuvent
générer des nuitées pour nos hôtels sur
saint quentin en yvelines 250 mille
mètres carrés de projets d'immobilier
d'entreprise sont en cours de
développement
jean michel fourgous en vous a vu dans
ces reportages saint-quentin-en-yvelines
donc avec cette casquette de président
de l'agglomération vous étiez présent le
simi apporte beaucoup c'est aussi
l'occasion au delà d'être une vitrine de
nouer des contacts
c'est le dvico le développement
économique
aujourd'hui est fondamental devant la
baisse dépend des moyens publics de
l'état
on a la chance nous donne à beaucoup
d'entreprises donc bien sûr on les aide
à augmenter leur activité et en
augmentant l'activité des entreprises
on nous demande mais sur les rucks est
aussi pour saint quentin donc il est
normal qu'on soit présent qu'on les aide
alors nous qu'est ce qu'on fait on
adapte toujours les nouveaux des
nouveaux bâtiments à l'évolution
du cadre de travail que les entreprises
ont demain il faut savoir qu'un employé
il sera pu appareiller son nombre
d'heures travaillées
on va regarder sa valeur ajoutée on va
regarder sa productivité
là c'est donc on voit bien que
l'ordination du du travail est en train
de complètement changer avec ça ça c'est
vous aurez le télétravail zh aujourd'hui
je me rends compte que les les jeunes
techniciens ingénieurs demande à des
grosses boîtes comme airbus ou thalès ou
d'autres de dire on veut que le temps de
transport puisque on regarde notre on
travaille sur notre ordinateur tablette
dont on veut que le transport sera
comptabilisé aussi bon donc on voit bien
que on est en train de réorganiser
complètement le monde du travail
donc on travaille là dessus et on ne
s'intéresse que c'est con on est très on
est maintenant dans mes soldes dans le
numérique très fortement marqué
culturellement on aide les chômeurs a
augmenté leur employabilité avec le
numérique donc s'appelle la transition
numérique donc on joue un rôle très
important pour les entreprises donc on
est très présent et un partenaire quand
même très actif je rappelle que la
majorité de mes des dix agents qui
travaillent avec moi sont des gens de
l'entreprise donc les gens
l'envahissante qu'ils ont une écoute
chez nous très particulière on les
comprend on les aime on est comme eux
que je veux dire que donc on aide à 2 p
51 montée on est déjà le deuxième pays
des par habitant après paris mais on
peut encore faire mieux quoi on est là
pour faire monter à traiter de façon
très dynamique
on quitte pour un temps la politique
avec un moment festif pour la communauté
juive en cette période de fin d'année
elle célèbre hanouka la fête des
lumières à montigny le bretonneux à
partager cette semaine ce moment avec et
les passants de la place choiseul c'est
dans une ambiance festive que s'est
retrouvé la communauté juive de montigny
le bretonneux sur la place estienne
françois choix seul pour célébrer à nous
car nous faisons ici sur la voie
publique
c'est justement pour montrer que dans
cette période qui est un peu obscur où
il ya un manque peut-être de tolérance
qu'au contraire c'est le moment il faut
ajouter de la lumière les fois on a
ajouté comme on le fait avec ce genre de
lier jour après jour on ajoute encore
une lumière lavande la communauté réunie
autour de cette célébration est à
l'extérieur c'est ça un grand symbole la
coutume veut que l'on attise une lumière
par jour de fête
le maire a allumé la flamme la plus
élevée celle qui sert à éclairer les
autres il faut que ce soit l'occasion de
rassembler les citoyens
vous voyez bien qu'actuellement en
france elle était d'aider tant
d'événements qui se produisent et on a
besoin de se rassembler à nuuk avait
aussi dire éducation c'est une fête où
la famille se rassemblent avec les
enfants c'est aussi un moment de partage
culturel des protestants sont venus en
signe de fraternité à luca c'est la fête
c'est la lumière comme disait monsieur
rabat est aussi la paternité entre nous
et avec tout ce qui se passe parce que
on doit savoir vivre avec les autres
ran cas c'est aussi l'occasion de se
régaler de béni traditionnelle en
référence aux miracles 2000 de chanter
et de danser puisque rannou cas est le
symbole de la lumière sur l'obscurité
mais aussi plus largement de la paix sur
la guerre on arrive déjà à la fin de cet
hebdo jean michel fourgous ce week end à
coignières le maire sera désigné par la
nouvelle liste qui a été un qui est
arrivé en tête celle de didier fischer
il devrait donc prendre la tête de la
commune de coignières peut-être une
réaction par rapport à ça et peut-être
dans l'avenir aussi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines didier fischer
n'a jamais caché que quitter saint
quentin en yvelines n'aurait pas été un
problème pour lui oui monsieur fisher a
été élu démocratiquement
donc moi je le recevrai joly au
téléphone et je le vois mercredi mais
sur pourquoi on
on arrête les règles de son intégration
dans notre équipe mais j'ai déjà des
gens de gauche avec qui ça se passe bien
c'est le vice-président j'imagine qui
lui sera proposé et a priori s'il est
pardonné si les demandeurs d'un poste
comme ça à priori très bonnes conditions
pour qu'il l'aide inquiète pas trop
aller comme du tous les autres maires
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez moi j'étais
très respectueux c'est vous l'interco
c'est ça il faut il faut jouer la
confiance on peut pas travailler contre
des maires on attire comme et moi je les
fais ça fonctionne ils sont très très
loyaux très règle très réglo et c'est
pour ça que peut-être que saint quentin
a les résultats assez extraordinaire en
développement économique est là et ce
sera la conclusion de cet hebdo le
journal revient à lundi il sera aussi
forcément question du téléthon juste un
récapitulatif qui va s'afficher de ce
que vous proposent les associations à
saint quentin en yvelines à retenir
notamment le premier téléthon d'ampleur
justement à coignières qui se mobilisent
samedi au gymnase du moulin-à-vent
programme à des communes à retrouver sur
les différents sites et puis dans notre
édition aussi du 7-8 loisirs disponible
en replay sur tv 78 points comme
n'oubliez pas le 36 37 pour vos dons à
lundi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]